I have it reject nation
I'm Greg Alba I'm John Humphrey one of
our top reward tiers at our patreon page
is whatever video you request we must do
a put up on YouTube today comes from a
fairly new patron eject named Pete dot
we've got to know this guy pretty well
he has a video request that made me
cringe awesome John doesn't know what it
is yet I'm excited to hear what it is he
wants us to react to our very first
video that's ever been uploaded on this
channel we can provide a lot of
information for this video cuz this
video wasn't intended to be like the
start of the real rejects it was just
some random video we did random skin it
wasn't even called the real rejects
soccer just eventually changes it to
when we wanted to make the channel we
just kept the video up man I am ready to
cringe let's don't worry Joel Harlow
Johnny Depp's personal makeup artist
loved your oh god yeah oh no one of the
highlights of your recent interview I've
been cast people there would be a few
awkward moments just for him today
you're like you're injecting those on
purpose it was an awkward like a year
before we even put it up no idea what we
were doing we were trying really are
such a like maytee title awesome
many views it's almost got as many
dislikes as likes okay here we go
[Music]
[Laughter]
well when I first read the screen live
for free microphone Rango so skinny a
half way through the script I realized I
think I'm getting better I think I got
the lizard
okay and from there characters is sort
of evolved yeah you've done children's
films before let's talk about Charlie
and the Chocolate Factory
how did you take an iconic role like
Willy Wonka and when I read the
screenplay for charging each other's
battery a half way through the script I
realized I'm Charlie and from there the
character just sort of man that royalty
how do you get into other historical
figures
what's your preparation for that halfway
through I realized hands up fire right
now
by the way now how would you use that to
interrogate well the first time
cut it when you act downstream I thought
to myself how could I use sense-memory
to get the real feeling of being sucked
into a bed so I thought of childbirth in
Reverse you know the baby crawling in
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Music]
what did you give to aspiring actors
well when you first get the script about
halfway through the script you're gonna
realize which character that's right
when we decided to reload it we put that
at the end it's a time capsule right
there that's a one year longest enduring
impression I think because my voice
naturally got deeper it's easier to make
that impression sound deeper yeah and
sort of how to pitch it low I smoked a
lot more since voice naturally go
because yeah we shot this like a year
before I don't even know what it is but
I just add that one little bit about
like how Johnny Depp behaves weirdly
when I was doing the the bit that I
always go to it doesn't sound good but I
thought that we're doing the in problem
like that seems weird to look back on
that and go wow actually when I
doing the Improv the mannerisms and
everything were more like what I see him
doing interviews yeah because maybe in
the improv bits you're walking around
inside of it more you know you're a
little more relaxed you're not beholden
to I think I think the impression has
beats to it yeah you know there's a
specific cadence to the when I first
read the screenplay like I feel like
that has its own rhythm and then when
you bust into this the random stuff at
the end it has a different rhythm
this is John's ex-girlfriend Lissa
Wagner yeah she's doing evil death
musical right now is she she was in one
video with us that was the Evil Dead
movie whoa
he's so torture bah bah and then keep in
touch there or something right I'm not a
great keep in touch her as I've learned
over time I remember yeah we keep in
touch I remember doing that and I
remember I never thought she thought it
was funny
but I remember she would break out
laughing in the middle of some of these
improv bits Hey this is such a pretty
like hey some of it is still pretty
funny to me and then other parts I'm
like this is such a mature YouTube but
what's funny is there are times we made
sketches and then a year to go by it I'm
like oh how we've gotten so much better
whenever we update the way we make
sketches always like oh man
this has gotten so much ya know he's
become cringe-worthy over I think the
thing was we were trying to make this
look better than what it is and then
when we started doing actual sketches
for this channel we sort of embraced the
lo-fi
yeah and made it always a part of the
jokes how we don't have the budgets how
we don't have a crew weird man yeah we
used it to make it funnier as opposed to
trying to mask stuff like with these
silly transitions the sex the music you
know we had terrible audio here oh yeah
this is pre Mike this was pre a lot of
things
yes likely yeah we were in the old
improv studio and it's funny it's yeah
cuz looking at these old sketches I'm
almost like hell of the techniques
improved and and oh man I mean this is
this is very simple but I was happy
about a couple things that showed
like when she scoots her Sharon she's
appropriately further into framing an
extra shot but we have learned is like
I'm watching like an embarrassing home
video I mean granted it's not me doing
this impression and I'm not in the video
at all that I thought I still think it's
charming
yeah I don't look back at this and go
you know like oh yeah we're not we're
just doing a cut between two takes
which I think you edited the whole thing
I had no idea how to edit anything back
then
I mean we've probably pored over
together in terms of timing probably
hours going over you bring this back a
little bit what about this version of
the joke yeah I forgot why we did there
was real no intention where we weren't
trying to start a channel we weren't
trying to do regular sketches there's
just something we shot just for fun and
then we just put it up one day and
eventually we decided called this the
real rejects we just changed the title
up yeah yeah we'd made little videos and
sketches over the years and stuff like
that so I feel like maybe it was another
one of those it was just sort of like
got this idea we got a space that we can
use like let's shoot this yeah and that
probably would have been around the time
that at least the ideas for doing more
and more video related stuff more
frequently would have been percolating
even if they weren't you know on the
front burner yet now when we have
moments where you cringe during our
sketches that's always intention stupid
that's it yeah that's that that's the
difference now it was like no we want
you take fringe here yeah usually when a
sketch comes out in someone comments
like oh this is so cringe Emily yeah
that's one of the ingredients yeah I'm
like it's supposed to be right yeah it's
supposed to be like oh this ain't high
quality yeah
always supposed to start off that way
yeah but this the élisa élisa really
gave it all cuz those are there any
vanilla herbal cigarettes but man they
smell like real cigarette oh yeah they
can fill up a poorly ventilated room but
hey I feel like once we reach our 10
year channel anniversary we should film
a redux to this sketch I think we should
redo it looking back in some of this the
whole you know when it was that that
part was a is all the same script
refused for years but when you go to the
arts world were just improvising
like the matter isms of the timing I'm
like yeah it's like how I remember
Johnny Depp he's like I can't even do
that now I would have to like remember
how to do that you have to get into
character again yeah and you'd have
probably have to get all those rings and
necklaces all yours
I know where every one of them came from
so it's like with context it's it's
extra silly without if it's decent
it was so skinny back then man that was
so much skinnier and the improv wig now
I then I got fat and now I got like this
weird halfway strong you're not skinny
nor my rib but I'm definitely stronger
than I am here yeah you could beat your
old self yeah I would yeah I mean the
old you might have like a speed
advantage but like you know you you
could probably knock his head
honestly just the embarrassing parts of
the music and the title awesome Johnny
Depp impression but I think even though
depending on how you view this video
kind of words because it's a little
silly the thing is that the Krynn here
is an intentional that's the difference
yeah I feel like now it wouldn't be hard
to retroactively LIGO that could be like
yeah awesome Johnny depression it's kind
of cool to like watch this and then you
know we were released the one before the
endgame review which was a big lesson in
like okay we got a lure to trim the fat
you know because we got a little
self-indulgent for sketches Rob or like
our sketches are law 20 so that one was
like no we have to hit the three minute
mark so if there were spots in that end
game sketch we were like no we got to
cut this we got to trim it we got
trimming it makes it a tighter sketch
now I'm like even watching this there's
ways we could affirm this rook they've
been tighter you know they made a flow
better and now we know how to light
better even this is better lighting is
making the most out of a couple hours
and not a ton yeah
uh well thanks Pete dawn for requesting
this buddy thanks for the walk down
memory lane and that we gave you a
shout-out
last month Pete but I wanted to say this
time when a sincere note since this is
looking at our first sketch first I
wanted to say that since you are an
aspiring writer to keep at it buddy from
everything we've talked about you
clearly have a lot of passion a lot of
imagination and I know we've talked
about how you can sometimes feel that
struggle to stay focused on one story at
a time or just stay on track it's a
discipline it's something that I rarely
succeed at but when I do it's very
rewarding and I'm telling you you can
achieve that euphoric feeling too amigo
I really enjoy getting to know you man
you or someone who has so much passion
and so much love just communicates when
we talk with one another I mean just
even asking us to go back check out our
very first video there's a weird level
of love there yeah so I want to thank
you for that amigo you are a heck of a
guy and thanks for requesting this man I
was repaired for a more cringy
experience wasn't as cringy buta way the
right amount of cringy yeah but you know
I think you should take this back and
redo the whole shout out in the Johnny
Depp voice though like yeah when I first
got your message
halfway through your message I realized
I'm messaging the wrong person Johnny
Depp runs a Patriots what it is it every
new video now it's just him talking
about how to run a different you know
subscribe if you're watching this video
subscribe